- Ahh!
♪ Brickleberry
- Have you ever
seen a cuter animal?
Look at that.
Oh I just wanna cuddle him.
- I need you to win,
so I can live in the
Governor's mansion.
- I'm running against a woman.
Of course I'm gonna win!
The Lord works in
mysterious ways,
and right now He
wants me to be rich.
Sick people, lost
souls, deep pockets,
blah blah blah.
Religion equals money!
- I saw him go that way,
with a flamethrower.
- Oh, I thought you were
bobbin' for French fries again.
Holy Christ, Malloy,
you are right!
I
am a
goddamn
adonis!
Oh yeah, I accidentally
sat on that.
- Really?
These too?
Looks like somebody fell
ass first into a yard sale.
- I just like to be organized.
I call it bung shui.
A bear ranger?
What's next?
Forgiving your dad for
making you wear panties
and a padded bra just 'cause
he missed his dead wife?
I'm not mom, dad!
She's gone!
Now we are blood
brothers for life.
We'll always have
each other's backs.
- [Both] Rich goals,
respect and protect.
- [Woody] Oh, there you go.
You need to look that angel
of death right in the eye,
and shout, "What
the shit is that?"
- Macho Man T-shirt.
- A Macho Man T-shirt?
- Seoul, South Korea.
- Ugh, goddammit!
♪ Brickleberry